my McAfee is a big one well Pat Mac
these are the biggest Pat McAfee is like
I know that somebody had told me that
bro yeah let me to do it and that's my
good friend your good friend to refer I
love that yeah look at eat anytime I've
anything that takes package podcast huge
way bigger than us dude we have three of
us in football he's like sports he
texted me the other day and he goes he
goes so our sport chatter is gonna be a
little low any interested in flying out
to Indiana this week diamond [ __ ] yeah
you should go I'd go hang with him have
you been to set right yeah so it's in
Indy and he has it's in it's in downtown
it's like a Rogen compound it's a Rogen
compound but it's in downtown Indy he
opens up the garage you walk in and it's
like studio basketball court
[ __ ] podcast bang where shooters show
upstairs merch like he just figured it
out he's the guy who was on bar stool he
played professional football he's a
punter pro baller not a big deal pro
baller plays with [ __ ] you know the
best guys in the world as far as golf
and do that he is the best everyone
loves them so the biggest names then I
felt gonna show they talked to him first
he's an amazing commentator so he does a
college football for ESPN he's on he's
on he'll go on first take who go on wake
up in the morning or where the [ __ ] it
is he does all of it good friend he's
the best he's a friend and he used to be
a hardcore partier now he just smokes
weed and just he did the announcement oh
did you see that for the Pelican for the
pelicans and like I mean changed the
game he's he's a he's a real funny I
think a lot of those punters are funny
interesting good him in that outfit oh
my oh and he's like WrestleMania my
favorite people I didn't know who he was
so he said so Tim when I got to in the
end they said Pat McAfee wanted you to
do a show and I go I don't know who that
is
I don't know how you don't play I was
like you know how it is that everybody
wants me to get a hot cast so I'm like
I'm not doing a podcast in Indiana but I
got I just got here and I got a bunch of
other [ __ ] to do and was the bigger and
then you told me that he's an amazing
guy and I'm like well as my boy
like this it Pat McAfee oh okay
he's so talented it told me he's so
[ __ ] talented I told him one time I
was like pretty confident that with very
minimal training I could be a
competitive field goal kicker in the NFL
oh and [ __ ] I lost it and then Burke
caught wind of it what's your field goal
Cairo just upon a putter everybody goes
to pro baller though it's about
exploding cities explain to me what a
pond are what makes a good punter and
what the responsibilities explosive the
putters you know they can control you
know where the ball goes
yes see distance height so so height so
you don't want hiccup dream :
you guys can get down there get half
McAfee kicks soccer ball a hundred and
twenty-five miles Pat Mackey kick a
soccer ball and it'll should come up
he's a freak yeah yeah big kick that's
good yeah just see what this is yeah
this one was shot yeah no that no he
kicked yeah watch it yeah that's it why
don't you kick some my soccer ball 124
miles per hour and by the way he he also
might up guys you ever seen him is his
highlights of Jesus you've seen the
highlights of him hitting guys in the
NFL oh yeah bring up that chin he put
helmets on people he's like a Japanese
fighter pilot in World War two you know
he [ __ ] he's got he's got explosive
power explosivity kickers do yeah that's
one thing he told me said you know what
the difference to me in US and I said no
what he goes explosivity yeah he goes I
have that's why I think Joe could get me
a legit field goal kicker yeah we play
basketball he's [ __ ] good man this is
by the way this is a placekicker field
goal kicker punter that's and look at he
also feel you also did some kill go look
at a punter low bow dude
with him lighting this dude up the best
or is on sidekicks what's this big right
he's about to take it to the house
usually I just last week about chop at
dimepiece girl oh yeah guys like that
guy alpha guys like that they get who
they want come on punish usually don't
watch this no helmet to help hey look at
me they're lucky they may get food on
the plane okay but he's different
hey punished done right nope dude look
one time I feel go kick on see you
missed the game-winning field goal you
know happen to him well we sound the
back to play me get fed that day yeah
they don't go through the same [ __ ] we
go through now paths different he's
different cuz he's pathways just watch
this here we go look at this
nothing like that guys still scored but
still I think punter has got to be the
funnest job because there is you just
the gayest but it's Superman
yeah he he was not scared to but here's
the thing be he's he's up he's cut from
the same cloth he was a really good
punter he's a he he's a nurse so he does
stand up that's he used to he did he
really his very first he's so stupid
he's walking like a burger it's time to
stand up one shot a special from 3,000
people she's huge fall huh yeah he was
have a special Brendan what he was first
understand because I I've released it on
the on YouTube and you know what it's
not bad cuz all it is is its locker room
Joe sure it's just these lockers expands
if there's a lot of guys I think I think
I was on a ball here you [ __ ]
quarterback in for a touchdown but yeah
there's a lot of guy it would have been
selling boats who plays a lot of guys me
the NFL and call me this feel on-site
here in the locker rooms you gotta
realize it's all roast uh-huh it's
roasting I notice that so football
players I noticed that more than any
other [ __ ] athlete are the most
socially adept and also the funniest
because they're always around each other
it's a team sport they're always [ __ ]
with each other so the football players
I know bond exactly but they also have
high social intelligence great senses of
humor totally can [ __ ] with you and
themselves yeah but their
self-deprecating says funny dude just
back around all these guys yeah any time
Matt Barnes you know Matt Barnes Matt
Barnes is great Mary Sanchez is gorgeous
you know yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your
tongue oh what's gonna happen what are
you gonna do use some of that boxing
you've been doing
[Laughter]